Shure: 听过吗啊
Shure: Have you heard it?
Alice:听过
Alice: Yes, I have.
Katrina: 真没听过
Katrina: Really haven't heard it.
Katrina: 听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard it?
Tasha:谁没听过
Tasha: Who hasn't heard it?
Nicous: 好老了
Nicous: It's so old.
Lucia:没听过
Lucia: Haven't heard it.
Shure: 完了哈哈
Shure: Oh no, haha.
Lucia:真没听过哈哈
Lucia: Really haven't heard it, haha.
Tasha:好像听过又好像没听过呢
Tasha: It feels like I've heard it but also haven't.
Shure: 朴树的
Shure: It's by Pu Shu.
Shure: 这首就比较欢快
Shure: This one is quite cheerful.
Jake:挺好这
Jake: This is nice.
Shure: 这是备选一
Shure: This is option one.
Jake:对备选可以
Jake: Yeah, option one works.
Katrina: 备选二是什么
Katrina: What's option two?
Shure: 备选二是
Shure: Option two is...
Katrina: 开心超人
Katrina: Happy Superman.
Shure: 开心超人
Shure: Happy Superman.
Shure: 大家小时候看过吗
Shure: Did you watch it as kids?
Shure: 完了你这
Shure: Oh no, you...
Shure: 明显跟我们有点代沟啊哈哈
Shure: There's clearly a generation gap here, haha.
Tasha:开心往前飞
Tasha: Happy flies forward.
Katrina: 对对对就是这首歌
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, that's the song.
Jake:然后还有
Jake: And then there's...
Jake:这是个动画片吗
Jake: Is this a cartoon?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Tasha:动画片
Tasha: Cartoon.
Jake:我确实也不知道
Jake: I really didn't know either.
Lucia:那行咱俩没代沟哈哈哈
Lucia: Well, that means we're not out of touch, haha.
Jake:这这这长什么样啊
Jake: What does it look like?
Jake:里边的角色
Jake: The characters inside.
Shure: 就是那个红色的
Shure: It's that red one.
Shure: 那个叫开心超人
Shure: It's called Happy Superman.
Jake:你认识这些这些玩意吗
Jake: Do you know these things?
Lucia:哦我见过
Lucia: Oh, I've seen them.
Jake:完了还是有带差
Jake: So, there's still a generation gap.
Lucia:但我没但我没看过
Lucia: But I haven't watched it.
Jake:我见都没见过我见过
Jake: I've never even seen it. I've seen it.
Jake:你知道这玩意吗
Jake: Do you know this thing?
Jake:你也不知道
Jake: You don't know either.
Nicous: 没看过但是知道这个人
Nicous: I haven't watched it, but I know the character.
Jake:这个人
Jake: This character.
Nicous: 一个水平
Nicous: At the same level.
Jake:哦水平还是比我高的
Jake: Oh, still better than me.
Shure: 那还有下一首是这个
Shure: Then the next song is this one.
Katrina: 你跳舞吗
Katrina: Do you dance?
Katrina: 不会吧
Katrina: Probably not.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 别猜哈
Shure: Don't guess.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:这确实又没听过
Jake: I've really never heard this.
Katrina: 有点疑惑了
Katrina: A bit confused.
Katrina: 哈哈哈好
Katrina: Hahaha, alright.
Jake:我这个虽然没听过但是很好唱的感觉
Jake: I haven't heard it, but it seems easy to sing.
Shure: 对很好唱
Shure: Yes, it's easy to sing.
Katrina: 三选一当开头
Katrina: Three choices for the opening.
Katrina: 三选一
Katrina: Three choices.
Shure: 咱们听过最多的就是那个
Shure: The one we've heard the most is that one.
Lucia: 难忘今宵
Lucia: Unforgettable Tonight.
Katrina: 难忘今宵在最后的我们
Katrina: Unforgettable Tonight is at our end.
Jake:开场难忘今宵
Jake: Start with Unforgettable Tonight.
Katrina: 开开开场要选
Katrina: For the opening, we should choose.
Jake:结束
Jake: Finish.
Jake:欢迎大家
Jake: Welcome everyone.
Lucia: 我投票给雨轩了
Lucia: I voted for Yuxuan.
Lucia:难忘今宵
Lucia: Unforgettable Tonight.
Lucia:好我一票已经送出去了
Lucia: Okay, I've cast my vote.
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's great.
Jake:难忘今宵
Jake: Unforgettable Tonight.
Nicous: 对对好我是
Nicous: Yeah, yeah, okay, I am...
Jake:我说开场我说开场我说开场开场对
Jake: I mean the opening, I mean the opening, I mean the opening, the opening, right?
Katrina: 但是我们要开头这是开场的
Katrina: But we need an introduction, this is the opening.
Tasha:难忘今宵是
Tasha: Unforgettable Tonight is...
Katrina: 难忘今宵能用吉他弹吗
Katrina: Can Unforgettable Tonight be played with a guitar?
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:摇滚难忘今宵
Jake: Rock version of Unforgettable Tonight.
Jake:可以吗啊要
Jake: Is that okay? Do you need...
Katrina: 那你好交给你了
Katrina: Then, okay, it's up to you.
Jake:行
Jake: Sure.
Lucia:租个琴吧
Lucia: Let's rent a piano.
Jake:他带过来的
Jake: He brought one.
Katrina: 他有
Katrina: He has one.
Lucia: 哦那可以
Lucia: Oh, that's fine then.
Shure: 那你怎么再搬回去呢
Shure: How will you move it back?
Shure: 能卖出去吗
Shure: Can you sell it?
Lucia:你是电钢琴还是电键盘了啊
Lucia: Is it an electric piano or a keyboard?
Nicous: 电钢
Nicous: Electric piano.
Lucia:哎那我也可以试试
Lucia: Oh, then I can try too.
Nicous: 大一买的
Nicous: Bought it in freshman year.
Nicous: 大一弹得多
Nicous: Played a lot in freshman year.
Jake:就三个选项吗
Jake: Are there only three options?
Katrina: 开场的就三选一
Katrina: For the opening, just pick one of the three.
Katrina: 三选一都已经选不出来了
Katrina: Can't even pick one out of three.
Lucia:你说竟然没有琴房
Lucia: You mean there's no piano room?
Lucia:好可怜啊拍拍
Lucia: So pitiful, pat pat.
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Nicous: 在沙河
Jake:行吧
Jake: Okay then.
Lucia:在沙河
Lucia: It's in Shahe.
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina: 公用什么
Katrina: A shared what?
Katrina: 就一个公用钢琴
Katrina: Just one shared piano.
Alice:沙河那个校区吗
Alice: The Shahe campus?
Lucia:还在沙河
Lucia: Still at Shahe.
Shure: 哎我他妈手机去哪去了
Shure: Hey, where the hell is my phone?
Katrina: 你自己选
Katrina: You choose.
Lucia:哦这样子
Katrina: 你选呗要不你哪个熟练就选哪个
Katrina: You choose, or pick the one you're most familiar with.
Lucia:我还以为我们学校琴房要付钱
Lucia: I thought we had to pay for the practice room at our school.
Jake:彩链纸
Jake: Colored paper chain.
Lucia:已经很不可思议了呢
Lucia: It's already quite unbelievable.
Shure: 那就
Shure: Then...
Shure: new boy吧大家感觉听的是听过得最多的
Shure: How about "New Boy"? Seems like everyone has heard it the most.
Jake:我们不用付钱
Jake: We don't have to pay.
Jake:因为没有
Jake: Because there's none.
Lucia:你说你说嗯你说
Lucia: You say it, yeah, you say it.
Katrina: 哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Jake:不是
Lucia:啊 好吧好吧对对对
Lucia: Ah, okay, okay, right, right.
Shure: 就来这首new boy好不好
Shure: Let's go with "New Boy", okay?
Katrina: 行牛boy
Katrina: Fine, "New Boy".
Jake:因为没有对
Jake: Because there's none, yeah.
Lucia:我以为你说在哪不用付钱
Lucia: I thought you meant where we don't have to pay.
Jake:没有我以为你说你在说牛boy
Jake: No, I thought you were talking about "New Boy".
Shure: 好 记住了吗
Shure: Okay, remember?
Tasha:new boy是怎么唱
Tasha: How do you sing "New Boy"?
Alice:没
Alice: No.
Lucia:啥
Lucia: What?
Shure: new boy
Shure: "New Boy".
Tasha:哪一首
Tasha: Which one?
Shure: 就是这时的我看见到处是阳光是吧
Shure: It's the one that goes, "I see sunshine everywhere," right?
Lucia:哪一首
Lucia: Which one?
Alice:哪首
Alice: Which one?
Alice:这个听过
Alice: I've heard this one.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 行那就这个
Katrina: Alright, let's go with this one.
Shure: 那就这个了
Shure: Let's go with this one.
Shure: 大家回去多加练习
Shure: Everyone, practice more when you go back.
Lucia:没听过
Lucia: I haven't heard it.
Alice:是什么这个要开场
Alice: What is this? Is this the opening?
Tasha:开场对
Tasha: Opening, yeah.
Shure: 对开场
Shure: Yes, opening.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Katrina: 但是我们几个人一起唱
Katrina: But we'll all sing together.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 跑调没关系
Katrina: It's okay to be off-key.
Alice:好 好
Alice: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 也没什么人看
Katrina: Not many people are watching anyway.
Shure: 说唱也行你就突然来呦
Shure: You could even rap, just go for it.
Shure: 就这样也可以
Shure: This works too.
Lucia:好你说lou那一段这是艰巨任务
Lucia: Okay, the part where you say "lou" is a tough task.
Lucia:交给你了
Lucia: It's all yours.
Katrina: 然后中
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 我们本来定的是两首
Katrina: We originally planned for two songs.
Katrina: 一手开场欢快一点
Katrina: One upbeat for the opening.
Katrina: 一手中间那种配合晚上那种悠闲
Katrina: And one mellow one to match the evening vibe.
Katrina: emo一点的那个
Katrina: The emo one.
Katrina: 选的是perfect和唯一二选一
Katrina: We chose between "Perfect" and "The Only One".
Katrina: 哎黄老板
Katrina: Hey, Nicous.
Shure: 你这个一定听过了吧
Shure: You've definitely heard this one, right?
Shure: 混欧美圈的啊
Shure: You're into Western music.
Lucia:啊哪个
Lucia: Which one?
Katrina: 黄老板的perfect
Katrina: Ed Sheeran's "Perfect".
Shure: 黄老板的perfect啊
Shure: Ed Sheeran's "Perfect".
Lucia:听过但我这个听的不多
Lucia: I've heard it, but not that much.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Lucia:黄老板听的最多的应该shape of you
Lucia: The one I listened to the most is "Shape of You".
Lucia:哈哈口水干了
Lucia: Haha, my mouth is dry.
Alice:哎呀我妈呀哈哈
Alice: Oh my, haha.
Katrina: 好像唯一不适合合唱
Katrina: Seems like "The Only One" isn't suitable for a duet.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 那我们要不
Shure: So, how about...
Shure: 你给大家solo一个女团舞吧
Shure: You do a solo girl group dance for everyone?
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:没有
Alice: No way.
Katrina: 我要跳也要拉着你
Katrina: If I dance, I'm pulling you in too.
Jake:你要不
Jake: How about you...
Tasha:你要不来一段吧
Tasha: How about you do a bit?
Tasha:哈哈哈你好合适啊
Tasha: Haha, you're perfect for it.
Shure: 我不行的
Shure: I can't do it.
Shure: 我害羞
Shure: I'm too shy.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 那就订perfect
Katrina: Let's go with "Perfect".
Jake:你跳一个
Jake: You dance.
Shure: perfect
Shure: Perfect
Jake:然后以后就是
Jake: And then in the future...
Katrina: 中间一一下
Katrina: Let's do it in the middle.
Alice:中间的不用合唱吧
Alice: We don't need to sing together in the middle, right?
Jake:以后这种计算机视觉的会议啊
Jake: In the future, for these computer vision conferences...
Katrina: 可以合唱啊
Katrina: We can sing together.
Jake:就会邀请你
Jake: They will invite you.
Katrina: 要不然就我俩
Katrina: Otherwise, just the two of us...
Katrina: 我俩会笑场
Katrina: The two of us will laugh.
Shure: 我就可以当学术蝗虫了是吧
Shure: I can be an academic locust, right?
Jake:不是就是会邀请你就去演出
Jake: No, they will invite you to perform.
Jake:当就是你知道那个妮娜
Jake: Just like, you know, Nina.
Shure: 妮娜是
Shure: Who's Nina?
Jake:就是信号处里的那个那个女的啊
Jake: The woman in the signal department.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:然后这种顶级会议都会邀请他去
Jake: Then these top conferences will always invite her.
Jake:然后这个
Jake: And then...
Shure: 那这样
Shure: So,
Shure: 以后就顶级会议都会邀请我去是吗
Shure: In the future, top conferences will invite me too, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:真的没有
Jake: Not really.
Shure: 每每次会给报差旅并且
Shure: Every time they'll cover travel expenses and...
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 部分劳务
Shure: Part of the labor costs.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:然后这个说是说土灵奖得主请你上台
Jake: And then they say, the Turing Award winner invites you on stage.
Jake:哇哇
Jake: Wow, wow.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 所以我手机去哪了
Shure: So where did my phone go?
Jake:所以你要不要跳
Jake: So, do you want to dance?
Alice:要的要的
Alice: Yes, yes!
Shure: 我不要我不要
Shure: No, no, I don't.
Shure: 哈哈哈你不要给我画这些饼
Shure: Hahaha, don't paint those pictures for me.
Lucia:跳跳跳你跳
Lucia: Dance, dance, you dance.
Lucia:我站你第二排
Lucia: I'll stand in the second row.
Lucia:就是你在我前面
Lucia: Just in front of me.
Lucia:我站你第二排给你伴舞
Lucia: I'll be in the second row dancing with you.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia:实际上那天徐璐正开始跳
Lucia: Actually, that day, Xu Lu started dancing.
Jake:说 说明这个
Jake: So, this means...
Katrina: 是我偷偷的从排后面下去了
Katrina: I secretly snuck down from the back.
Katrina: 是吧哈哈
Katrina: Right? Haha.
Alice:我们一共准备三首歌吗
Alice: Did we prepare three songs in total?
Shure: 两两首难忘今宵
Shure: Two, two songs of "Unforgettable Tonight".
Katrina: 难忘今宵
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight".
Shure: 是
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 唱吗
Katrina: Sing?
Shure: 拿音响放吧
Shure: Let's play it on the sound system.
Katrina: 拿音响放
Katrina: Play it on the sound system.
Katrina: 然后我们就合一合
Katrina: Then we'll sing together.
Katrina: 难忘今宵你先一边收拾碟子一边
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight", you can start tidying up the dishes while...
Nicous: 我草我把它拍出来了
Nicous: Damn, I filmed it.
Jake:按出来啥了
Jake: What did you film?
Shure: 哦f和弦
Shure: Oh, an F chord.
Shure: 行那就这么定了
Shure: Alright, let's settle on that.
Shure: 第二首的话
Shure: For the second song...
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey,
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Shure: 不是这个不是
Shure: No, not this one.
Shure: 这个perfect大家没听过吧
Shure: Has everyone heard this "Perfect"?
Jake:听过
Jake: Heard it.
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Jake:唱个太多的新歌
Jake: Too many new songs.
Jake:新歌新歌
Jake: New songs, new songs.
Jake:不行老歌吧
Jake: No, old songs then.
Shure: 这个大家听过吧
Shure: Has everyone heard this one?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Shure: 大家都听过什么比较舒缓一点的歌
Shure: What relaxing songs has everyone heard?
Lucia:第二首竟然要舒缓一点的
Lucia: The second one needs to be a bit more relaxing?
Shure: 对一人报一首
Shure: Yes, each person suggests one.
Alice:想不起来
Alice: Can't think of any.
Shure: 舒缓的
Shure: Relaxing ones.
Shure: 我教大家唱我们乐队的原创歌曲吧
Shure: I'll teach everyone to sing an original song from our band.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哎那耳熟能详一点的那种
Katrina: How about something more familiar?
Jake:草与虫之歌
Jake: "Song of Grass and Bugs"?
Lucia:搞笑
Lucia: Funny.
Lucia:周杰伦的舒缓一些
Lucia: Jay Chou's more relaxing ones.
Katrina: 安静然后再叫安静
Katrina: Quiet, then call for quiet again.
Shure: 晴天
Shure: Sunny day.
Jake:一谋哥
Jake: Yi Mou Ge
Shure: 晴天大家听过吗
Shure: Have you all heard of "Sunny Day"?
Katrina: 谁没听过呀
Katrina: Who hasn't heard of it?
Shure: 那不行就这个吧
Shure: If not, let's go with this one.
Shure: 我搜一下晴天
Shure: I'll search for "Sunny Day."
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 在晚上唱晴天
Katrina: Singing "Sunny Day" at night?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Alice:那就唱夜曲吧
Alice: Then let's sing "Nocturne."
Tasha:晚上唱夜曲
Tasha: Sing "Nocturne" at night.
Jake:晚上唱夜曲
Jake: Sing "Nocturne" at night.
Alice:晚上唱夜曲
Alice: Sing "Nocturne" at night.
Shure: 啊我知道来吧
Shure: Ah, I know, let's do it.
Shure: OK就是这个样子
Shure: OK, just like this.
Katrina: 你哼一下
Katrina: Hum a bit.
Katrina: 到哪了
Katrina: Where are we?
Katrina: 行那就这首
Katrina: Alright, let's go with this one.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure: 太棒了
Shure: Awesome.
Katrina: 简单
Katrina: Easy.
Katrina: 定了
Katrina: It's settled.
Shure: 我们定完了
Shure: We've decided.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 到时候收尾就是你钢琴独奏一下
Katrina: At the end, you do a piano solo.
Nicous: 那个我们是不是要搞点英文歌
Nicous: Should we do some English songs?
Tasha:英文歌
Tasha: English songs?
Shure: 新加坡新加坡国语普及率很高
Shure: Singapore has a high Mandarin proficiency.
Lucia:可以可以我支持
Lucia: Sure, sure, I support that.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 再自由组合呗
Katrina: Then just freely combine.
Katrina: 想想
Katrina: Think about it.
Katrina: 想唱的或者想弹的就自由组合呗
Katrina: Sing or play whatever you want, just freely combine.
Katrina: 就是这个
Katrina: That's it.
Katrina: 就是放在晚上的那个环节
Katrina: Put it in the evening segment.
Katrina: 就是吃完晚饭那个环节
Katrina: The segment after dinner.
Katrina: 也可以邀请别人他们一起
Katrina: You can also invite others to join in.
Alice:哎嘉宾到晚上几点结束啊
Alice: Hey, what time do the guests leave at night?
Katrina: 8点 8点
Katrina: 8 o'clock, 8 o'clock.
Alice:他们吃饭吗
Alice: Are they eating?
Alice:需要吃的吧
Alice: They need food, right?
Katrina: 就是不是说点披萨吗
Katrina: Weren't we talking about ordering pizza?
Katrina: 晚上嗯
Katrina: For dinner, yeah.
Jake:傍晚吧对
Jake: Around evening, right?
Tasha:傍晚达美乐
Tasha: Evening, Domino's.
Jake:对对对超级大披萨
Jake: Yeah, yeah, the super large pizza.
Shure: 秋吧蘸点披萨
Shure: Oh, let's dip some pizza in the fall.
Shure: 有那个超级大披
Shure: They've got that super large pizza.
Shure: 你练习吧
Shure: You practice.
Shure: 我觉得你们的讨论
Shure: I think your discussion...
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 已经有有了一个结果
Shure: ...has already reached a conclusion.
Lucia:好难夹
Lucia: So hard to pick up.
Shure: 嗯那我们
Shure: Yeah, then we...
Jake:那我们最后干嘛呢
Jake: So what are we doing in the end?
Jake:最后一天干嘛来着
Jake: What were we doing on the last day?
Jake:先唱这三首歌
Jake: Sing these three songs first.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Shure: 先唱两首
Shure: Sing two songs first.
Shure: 然后最后放难忘今宵
Shure: Then play "Unforgettable Tonight" at the end.
Shure: 就是散场的时候放难忘今宵
Shure: Play "Unforgettable Tonight" when the event ends.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:好然后先唱两首歌啊
Jake: Alright, let's sing two songs first.
Katrina: 其实如果有自己想唱的就到时候
Katrina: Actually, if anyone wants to sing, just...
Katrina: 反正连伴奏嘛
Katrina: We can just use the karaoke backing tracks.
Katrina: 连全民k歌伴奏
Katrina: Use the karaoke backing tracks.
Jake:对  对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 然后自己自己练就行
Katrina: And just practice on your own.
Jake:嗯先唱两首歌
Jake: Yeah, let's sing two songs first.
Jake:然后室友问答是吗
Jake: Then roommate Q&A, right?
Tasha:卡拉自助是呗
Tasha: Karaoke self-service, right?
Katrina: 卡拉自助晚上没有问答
Katrina: Karaoke self-service doesn't have Q&A at night.
Katrina: 问答是下午那天定的
Katrina: The Q&A is scheduled for the afternoon.
Jake:对那那个内容是
Jake: Right, so we need to finalize the content.
Jake:得定一下对
Jake: We need to finalize it.
Katrina: 知识问答
Katrina: Knowledge Q&A.
Katrina: 对明天准备一下
Katrina: Yeah, prepare for it tomorrow.
Shure: 对明天准备一下
Shure: Yeah, prepare for it tomorrow.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: QQ给我们出一个
Katrina: QQ, give us one.
Lucia:写一下
Lucia: Write it down.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure: 然后大家记得通知自己的嘉宾
Shure: And everyone, remember to inform your guests.
Shure: 就是带一点闲置的二手物品
Shure: Just bring some idle second-hand items.
Shure: 来进行拍卖
Shure: For auction.
Shure: 交换好吧
Shure: Exchange, alright?
Katrina: 这个闲置二手物品是交换给谁
Katrina: Who are we exchanging these idle second-hand items with?
Katrina: 交换给我们
Katrina: Exchanging with us?
Katrina: 还是他们
Katrina: Or them?
Katrina: 交换就是拍卖吧
Katrina: Exchange means auction, right?
Shure: 就是谁谁都可以来买
Shure: Anyone can buy it.
Shure: 就是比如说好的
Shure: For example, okay.
Shure: 我现在拍卖这个
Shure: I am now auctioning this.
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This, this.
Shure: 我珍藏多年的酱香型白酒
Shure: My aged sauce-flavored white wine.
Shure: 嗯自
Shure: Hmm, from
Shure: 打我爷爷那年
Shure: my grandpa's time.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 对我这是做了一个违背祖宗的决定
Shure: Yeah, I am making a decision that goes against my ancestors.
Shure: 今天把这瓶酒拍卖给大家了
Shure: Today, I’m auctioning this bottle of wine to everyone.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 然后我觉得这瓶酒的起拍价是
Shure: And I think the starting price for this bottle is
Alice:两块
Alice: Two bucks.
Shure: 两个一钩一钩币
Shure: Two, one hook coin each.
Shure: 好吧我们就叫一钩币
Shure: Alright, we’ll call it hook coin.
Jake:好一钩币可以一个coin
Jake: Okay, one hook coin can be one coin.
Tasha:一个coin一钩
Tasha: One coin, one hook.
Jake:很虚拟啊这个
Jake: This is very virtual.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 我们把每个那个小币都上链吧
Shure: Let’s put each of those coins on the chain.
Lucia:多少数啊
Lucia: How many?
Lucia:可以把它注一下
Lucia: Can we note it down?
Shure: 一勾臂
Shure: One hook coin.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Jake:对对对好
Jake: Yes, yes, alright.
Shure: 可以那就这么定了
Shure: Okay, it's settled then.
Shure: 好
Shure: Good.
Shure: 然后明天商量一下具体的细则
Shure: Then let's discuss the specific details tomorrow.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 复现一下
Shure: Let's review it.
Shure: 我们
Shure: We
Jake:再捋一遍那个时间线啊
Jake: Let's go over the timeline again.
Katrina: 三点啊 2点半到3点是
Katrina: Three o'clock, or 2:30 to 3:00 is
Alice:嘉宾入场
Alice: Guest arrival.
Jake:2点半到3点
Jake: 2:30 to 3:00
Jake:对嘉宾入场
Jake: Yes, guest arrival.
Jake:3点开始
Jake: Starts at 3:00.
Jake:赚钱是吧
Jake: Making money, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Exactly.
Jake:三点开始自我介绍
Jake: Self-introductions start at 3:00.
Shure: 或者是讲故事
Shure: Or storytelling.
Jake:呃给多少钱呢
Jake: Uh, how much are we paying?
Shure: 看我们心情给
Shure: Depends on our mood.
Jake:就是我们作为家
Jake: As the hosts,
Jake:就我们作为评委是吧
Jake: as the judges, right?
Jake:评委
Jake:我们就坐着小板凳
Jake: We'll just sit on small stools
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Katrina: 那一上来就让他们自我介绍嘛
Katrina: Let's have them introduce themselves first
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Shure: 我们先表演节目暖场
Shure: Let's perform something first to warm up
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure
Katrina: 表演什么节目
Katrina: What are we performing?
Shure: 我们给大家唱一个
Shure: We'll sing something for everyone
Shure: 哈哈哈我给大家咬个打火机
Shure: Haha, or I'll bite a lighter for everyone
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:咬个什么打火机
Alice: Bite a lighter? What?
Shure: 你不知道这个梗吗
Shure: You don't know this joke?
Shure: 没活就咬打火机吧
Shure: When there's nothing to do, bite a lighter
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 你这就是
Shure: You're just...
Shure: 哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, alright, alright
Nicous: 会牙咬不动
Nicous: Your teeth won't handle it
Katrina: 那天说了先干嘛来着
Katrina: What did we say we would do first that day?
Katrina: 自我介绍前面还有一个环节
Jake:还有一个game
Jake: There's another game.
Jake:game before party
Jake: game before party
Shure: game before party是啥来着
Shure: What is game before party again?
Jake:拼那个拼图吗
Jake: Is it the puzzle one?
Shure: 啊啊啊对对对
Shure: Ah, yeah, yeah, that's it.
Tasha:那个的拼好
Tasha: That puzzle is done.
Lucia:不容易拼好
Lucia: It's not easy to finish.
Jake:哈哈哈很难拼哦
Jake: Hahaha, it's really hard.
Lucia:别打伞或者别的game
Lucia: Don't play "umbrella" or other games.
Jake:别打伞或者别的game
Jake: Don't play "umbrella" or other games.
Jake:还有就是藏东西在你们各种各地方
Jake: And also hide things all around the place.
Lucia:复活节彩蛋
Lucia: Like Easter eggs.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 那有点
Shure: That’s a bit...
Shure: 哦藏币是吧
Shure: Oh, hiding coins, right?
Jake:对藏币
Jake: Yeah, hiding coins.
Shure: :然后这个拿拿到就归他们
Shure: And then whoever finds them gets to keep them.
Jake:是藏币
Jake: Yes, hiding coins.
Shure: 对对对一些散币对
Shure: Yeah, yeah, some scattered coins.
Shure: 1,000 来
Shure: 1,000 coins, let’s go.
Shure: 哈哈哈我们我们撒一些币
Shure: Hahaha, we’ll scatter some coins.
Shure: 简称撒币
Shure: We call it "scattering coins."
Lucia:你先挖矿环节
Lucia: You start with the mining segment.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:对对行
Jake: Right, right, okay.
Jake:那明天我们撒就撒
Jake: So tomorrow we’ll scatter coins.
Jake:对明天我们当撒撒币
Jake: Yes, tomorrow we’ll do the coin scattering.
Jake:嗯哈哈
Jake: Mm-hmm, haha.
Jake:明天撒撒币
Jake: Tomorrow we scatter coins.
Shure: 明天撒撒币
Shure: Scatter coins tomorrow.
Jake:撒撒币啊
Jake: Scatter coins.
Jake:明天撒撒币啊
Jake: Scatter coins tomorrow.
Jake:我们50个币
Jake: We have 50 coins.
Jake:我们多少币
Jake: How many coins do we have?
Lucia:我们多少币
Lucia: How many coins do we have?
Lucia:150个
Lucia: 150.
Jake:150个币
Jake: 150 coins.
Shure: 150个
Shure: 150.
Jake:撒他
Jake: Scatter them.
Tasha: 50个
Tasha: 50 coins.
Jake:我不行 撒它20个吧
Jake: I can't do it. Scatter 20 coins then.
Shure: 有点太多了
Shure: That's a bit much.
Lucia:20
Lucia: 20
Jake:撒他20个币
Jake: Give him 20 coins.
Jake:哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Lucia:光撒的只是一部分OK
Lucia: Just giving a part of it, OK?
Jake:对撒他20个币
Jake: Yes, give him 20 coins.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Jake:不能全撒
Jake: We can't give it all.
Jake:对要保证金融市场有存货
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 我是这边记得是两点半到3点入场
Katrina: I remember it starts at 2:30 PM and ends at 3 PM.
Katrina: 然后introduction and Q&A是3点到3:40
Katrina: Then the introduction and Q&A is from 3 PM to 3:40 PM.
Katrina: 嗯那这个暖场游戏是啥时候呢
Katrina: So, when is the warm-up game?
Katrina: 就在2点半到3点之间
Katrina: It's between 2:30 PM and 3 PM.
Jake:对 2点半到三点
Jake: Yes, 2:30 PM to 3 PM.
Tasha:暖场是什么游戏
Tasha: What's the warm-up game?
Jake:来的人就来
Jake: Whoever comes, comes.
Katrina: 找币
Katrina: Find coins.
Jake:对找币
Jake: Yes, find coins.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Katrina: 找币
Katrina: Find coins.
Katrina: 然后想玩那个拼图的就玩拼图
Katrina: And if you want to do puzzles, do puzzles.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Jake:然后如果拼起来的话
Jake: And if you finish the puzzle...
Katrina: 可以奖励
Katrina: There's a reward.
Katrina: 拼不起来的
Katrina: If you can't finish it...
Lucia:拼不起来放心吧
Lucia: Don't worry, you won't finish it.
Jake:最确实确实
Jake: That's true, true.
Alice:要不按照块拼吧
Alice: How about we do it piece by piece?
修确：就是你拼到几个
Shure: Like, see how many pieces you can do.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 那总共有几个块来着
Shure: So how many pieces are there in total?
Alice:好几十个吧
Alice: Probably dozens.
Jake:我 就
Jake: I just...
Jake:你们作为每拼起来的人
Jake: For each person who finishes it...
Jake:就就大概点评一下给个稍为
Jake: Just give a brief comment and a small reward.
Jake:随便给点钱吧要不就
Jake: Maybe some money or something.
Shure: 每拼进去多少个
Shure: For each piece they complete...
Shure: 然后我们给
Shure: We give them something.
Shure: 就比如说每拼进5个
Shure: For example, every time you complete 5...
Shure: 我可以给你一个
Shure: I can give you one.
Shure: 你要能拼
Shure: If you can complete them.
Tasha:拼5个就给一个币啊
Tasha: So if I complete 5, I get one coin?
Tasha:你这小抠搜
Tasha: You're being so stingy.
Tasha:抠搜的
Tasha: So stingy.
Alice:你知道那个有多难吗
Alice: Do you know how hard that is?
Lucia:知道有多难吗
Lucia: Do you know how hard that is?
Alice:我都快拼瞎了
Alice: I'm almost going blind trying to complete them.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No, it's not like that.
Jake:哈哈哈一个币很难挣的
Jake: Hahaha, earning one coin is really tough.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 你这是破坏市场
Shure: You're messing up the market.
Jake:你知道现在一个
Jake: Do you know now...
Tasha:你才是
Tasha:你知道现在一个矿业吗
Tasha: Do you know how the mining industry is now?
Tasha:真的剥削你知道吗
Tasha: It's real exploitation, you know that?
Jake:一个矿业多少钱吗
Jake: Do you know how much one mining operation costs?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Lucia: 你说是big矿业吗
Lucia: Are you talking about big mining operations?
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Lucia:他说一个矿多少钱
Lucia: He said how much one mining operation costs.
Lucia:我说是比特币吗
Lucia: I asked if he meant Bitcoin mining.
Jake:哈哈哈这差不多吧
Jake: Hahaha, something like that.
Jake:一开始也不值钱对吧
Jake: It wasn't worth much initially, right?
Alice:我们都快拼瞎了
Alice: We're almost going blind trying to complete them.
Lucia:那你真得把咱这上链上链
Lucia: You really need to put our work on the blockchain.
Lucia:给他注成NFT算了
Lucia: Turn it into an NFT or something.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then what?
Alice:没关系要不然就按时间吧
Alice: Never mind, maybe we should do it based on time.
Alice:他们嗯
Alice: They...
Alice:不管拼成什么样
Alice: No matter how well they complete it.
Alice:能坐上15分钟就给他个两三个之类的
Alice: If they can sit for 15 minutes, give them two or three coins or something.
Jake:什么呀什么东西
Jake: What's that? What's that thing?
Lucia:木子膏呀
Lucia: Muzigao.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 你不知道这
Shure: You don't know this?
Lucia:有一首歌
Lucia: There's a song.
Shure: 是的热狗的一首歌叫做NFT
Shure: Yes, a song by Hotdog called "NFT".
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:听懂一个词
Jake: Understood one word.
Lucia: 感觉都是哔哔哔
Lucia: Feels like it's all beep beep beep.
Lucia:哈哈哈对自带消音效果
Lucia: Hahaha, yeah, it's like it's automatically censored.
Shure: 可以听一下这个词
Shure: You can listen to this word.
Katrina: 那就这样
Katrina: So that's it.
Katrina: 3点哈哈哈
Katrina: 3 o'clock, hahaha.
Jake:行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Katrina: 3点到3:40是他们自我介绍
Katrina: From 3 to 3:40 is their self-introduction.
Katrina: 和我们的知识问答
Katrina: And our Q&A session.
Katrina: 然后3:40到4:20是我们host part
Katrina: Then from 3:40 to 4:20 is our host part.
Katrina: 就是我们介绍我们每个人的东西
Katrina: It's where we introduce our stuff.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 4:20到5点是他们介绍他们带来的东西
Katrina: From 4:20 to 5, they will introduce their stuff.
Katrina: 拍卖嗯
Katrina: Auction, yeah.
Katrina: 然后5点半左右就是订的
Katrina: Then around 5:30, we will order.
Katrina: 然后就是披萨
Katrina: And then it's pizza.
Katrina: 然后6点
Katrina: And then at 6.
Katrina: 6点多的时候就可以开始唱
Katrina: Around 6, we can start singing.
Katrina: 唱歌什么的
Katrina: Singing and stuff.
Katrina: 晚上就指定了
Katrina: In the evening, it's set.
Katrina: 唱歌好像
Katrina: Singing, I think.
Jake:对晚上没啥大事
Katrina: 哦哦我想起来就是那个呃
Katrina: Oh, oh, I remember, it's that uh...
Katrina: 4:20 host part结束以后最后压轴的是他们
Katrina: After the host part at 4:20, the final highlight is them.
Katrina: 然后就可以尝一下他的甜品嗯
Katrina: Then we can taste their dessert, yeah.
Jake:啊是我不是
Jake: Ah, it's me, isn't it?
Jake:这本来就是吗
Jake: Wasn't it always like this?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake:嗑完为
Jake: After finishing it.
Katrina: 早上做来得及吗
Katrina: Is it enough time to make it in the morning?
Shure: 哎不行
Shure: Eh, no.
Katrina: 3点才开始嘞
Katrina: It only starts at 3.
Shure: 卫多美哈哈哈哈
Shure: Weidomei, hahaha.
Lucia: 番茄沙司吗
Lucia: Ketchup?
Shure: 好利来没说
Shure: Holiland didn't say.
Shure: 卫多美可能不知道
Shure: Weidomei might not know.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 然后那个什么调节
Katrina: Then what adjustment...
Shure: 卢锡河
Shure: Luxihe.
Katrina: 今天晚上就指定了一个这个活动
Katrina: Tonight's event is set.
Katrina: 唱唱歌然后8点结束
Katrina: We'll sing some songs and finish by 8.
Katrina: 差不多6点开
Katrina: Starting around 6.
Katrina: 6点半的
Katrina: Maybe 6:30.
Katrina: 晚饭的话可能6:15开始吧
Katrina: Dinner might start at 6:15.
Katrina: 6:15-8点唱歌一个多小时
Katrina: So, singing from 6:15 to 8, about an hour and a half.
Katrina: 嗯嗯没了
Katrina: Yeah, that's all.
Shure: 行我们批一点
Shure: Sure, we'll approve that.
Jake:差不多嗯那
Jake: Yeah, sounds good.
Shure: 不要那么高
Shure: Don't make it too high.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:咱那个barbecue是啥意思
Jake: What's the deal with the barbecue?
Katrina: barbeque还搞吗
Katrina: Are we still doing the barbecue?
Katrina: barbeque那碳昨天剩了半天
Katrina: We had half a day’s worth of charcoal left from yesterday.
Jake:咋现在啥意思
Jake: So, what's the plan now?
Jake:要不从明天开始烧吧
Jake: Maybe we should start grilling tomorrow?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 烧没了给
Shure: Burn it all up.
Katrina: 这很难找
Katrina: It's hard to find.
Lucia: 这很难烧
Lucia: It's hard to grill.
Shure: 那个有点太困难了
Shure: That's a bit too challenging.
Nicous: 那你不是东北人吗
Nicous: Aren't you from the northeast?
Jake:哈哈哈东北人
Jake: Hahaha, northeast people.
Tasha:咱肯定能取火那个碳还烧不烧
Tasha: We can definitely light the charcoal. Are we grilling it?
Shure: 是不是
Shure: Right?
Shure: 是不是咱们昨天自个吃上了吧
Shure: Didn't we eat it ourselves yesterday?
Jake:是吃上了
Jake: Yeah, we did.
Lucia:是
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:花了两个小时吃上了
Jake: Took two hours to eat.
Jake:那如果要搞barbecue的话
Jake: If we're doing barbecue...
Katrina: 不是明天又得去采购吗
Katrina: Don’t we have to shop again tomorrow?
Jake:是买点直接买点串好的之类的
Jake: Just buy some pre-made skewers.
Jake:就美团嘛是吧
Jake: From Meituan, right?
Lucia:要不别烤了
Lucia: Or we could skip grilling.
Shure: 要不直接点熟的
Shure: Or just order ready-to-eat.
Jake:熟的直接烧
Jake: Ready-to-eat, just heat it up.
Jake:对熟的然后再在烤箱上面温
Jake: Yeah, ready-to-eat and then warm it up in the oven.
Shure: 温着温着
Shure: Warm it up.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 因为这个烧起来的时间
Lucia: Because grilling takes a lot of time.
Lucia:可能是三到更无穷所以就太难控制了
Lucia: Maybe it's from three to infinity, so it's hard to control.
Katrina: 还有咱那个酒的那个饮料也没了
Katrina: Also, our alcoholic drinks are out.
Katrina: 我们那个酒的饮料啊
Katrina: Our alcoholic drinks, you know.
Katrina: 维他
Katrina: Vita
Shure: 酒yes维他
Shure: Alcohol, yes, Vita.
Katrina: 外卖吧
Katrina: Let's order delivery.
Shure: 然后哦
Shure: Then, oh.
Shure: 明天那个dinner time的时候喷个香槟
Shure: Tomorrow during dinner time, let's pop some champagne.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Jake:哦这回给力点哈给力点
Jake: Oh, let's make it more exciting this time, okay?
Shure: 这这回必须得优雅的
Shure: This time, it has to be elegant.
Shure: 这回我就手崩坏了
Shure: This time, my hand might break.
Shure: 我都得把这香槟崩出去
Shure: I have to pop that champagne.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 哈哈哈要么就是我手飞出去
Shure: Haha, either my hand flies off,
Shure: 要么就是盖飞出去
Shure: Or the cap flies off.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这吓人
Katrina: That's scary.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 没了
Katrina: We're out.
Jake:没了
Jake: We're out.
Shure: 没了
Shure: We're out.
Shure: 要不就这样
Shure: How about we just leave it at that?
Jake:就这样
Jake: Just leave it at that.
Shure: 那休息
Shure: Then rest.
Tasha:还有装饰房间的
Tasha: And we still need to decorate the room.
Jake:装饰房间是
Jake: Decorate the room...
Katrina: 装饰房间
Katrina: Decorate the room.
Katrina: 要给他们看吗
Katrina: Should we show them?
Katrina: 还是就我们自己内部看看
Katrina: Or just keep it internal?
Jake:呃他给他们看
Jake: Uh, show them.
Jake:因为不是不是藏东西得
Jake: Because we're not hiding anything.
Tasha: 藏到房间里
Tasha: Hide it in the room.
Jake:合适吗
Jake: Is that appropriate?
Shure: 不合适吧
Shure: Not appropriate, right?
Jake:不合适
Jake: Not appropriate.
Shure: 哈哈哈你笑什么
Shure: Hahaha, why are you laughing?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 没笑
Katrina: Not laughing.
Shure: 你仿佛看到了什么一样
Shure: It's like you've seen something.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Katrina: 没看见
Katrina: Didn't see it
Shure: 不是你脸为什么那么红
Shure: Why is your face so red?
Shure: 你看到我什么了吗
Shure: Did you see something?
Jake:喝了吗
Jake: Did you drink?
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No
Katrina: 哈哈哈我脸红了吗我没喝
Katrina: Haha, is my face red? I didn't drink
Nicous: 喝橙汁配芒果汁就行
Nicous: Just drink orange juice with mango juice
Jake:是
Jake: Yeah
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed
Katrina: 那就那个环节设置在哪啊
Katrina: So where should that segment be?
Jake:那个环节
Jake: That segment
Jake:incho吧就在这
Jake: Incho, right here
Jake:可能Q a之前就是暖场吧
Jake: Maybe before Q&A, just to warm up
Katrina: 就是两点半到三点
Katrina: From 2:30 to 3:00
Jake:对两点半到三
Jake: Yeah, 2:30 to 3:00
Jake:三点一开始先暖个场吧
Jake: At 3:00, let's warm up a bit
Jake:大家转一圈
Jake: Everyone walks around
Jake:然后坐坐到座位上
Jake: Then sit down
Katrina: OK对那就
Katrina: Okay, let's
Jake:就是三点
Jake: So, at 3:00
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Got it
Jake:大家游戏
Jake: Everyone plays games
Jake:就是在客厅这边
Jake: In the living room
Jake:把币给把撒的币给找着
Jake: Find the scattered coins
Jake:然后找完之后就开始开始
Jake: After finding them, we start
Jake:然后大家每个人带他们走一圈
Jake: Then everyone leads a lap
Jake:走一圈之后买东西
Jake: After a lap, buy stuff
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Katrina: 行
Katrina: Got it
Jake:行
Jake: Got it
Shure: 杨老板应该做个总体的presentation呢
Shure: Jake should do a general presentation
Jake:做做一个
Jake: I'll do one
Jake:做个开场呗
Jake: Do an opening
Jake:对欢迎各位嘉宾各位领导
Jake: Yes, welcome guests and leaders
Shure: 杨老板得做一个小的小的答辩是吧
Shure: Jake should do a small defense, right?
Shure: 对我们为难为难他
Shure: Yeah, let's make it tough for him
Shure: 为什么要这么做
Shure: Why are you doing this?
Shure: 百度让我这么做的哈哈哈
Shure: Baidu told me to, hahaha
Shure: 这就是我的答辩
Shure: This is my defense.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 我真的挺好答的
Shure: It was actually pretty easy to answer.
Lucia:只答不辩
Lucia: Just answer without debate.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:那就收工
Jake: Let's wrap it up then.
Jake:收工
Jake: Wrapping up.
Jake:关 卡
Jake: Turn off the card.
Shure: 交还
Shure: Return it.
Shure: 哎呦终于找着我手机
Shure: Oh, finally found my phone.